يبدو بالتأكيد كما لو أن
العمليات الهجومية في أوكرانيا تكتسب زخمًا ، حيث
قال الأوكرانيون يوم الأحد إنهم
استعادوا عدة قرى من
الروس ، ومعظم ذلك يحدث في
الجزء الجنوبي الشرقي من
خط المواجهة الطويل جدًا هنا في هذا البلد
وهذا بالطبع أيضًا.  يأتي بعد أن
بدأت الأمور بداية صعبة في
نهاية الأسبوع الماضي حيث
نشر الروس مقطعين فيديو يزعمون أنهم
دمروا الكثير من الدروع في الكثير من
الدروع الغربية فيما قالوا إنها
عمليات فاشلة من قبل الأوكرانيين
لمحاولة  واكتساب أراضي في
الجزء الجنوبي من أوكرانيا الآن
لا يزال الأوكرانيون لا يسمون هذا
الهجوم بأنه هجوم مضاد كبير ، كانت هناك بعض
المؤشرات من قبل الرئيس الأوكراني في
نهاية هذا الأسبوع تقول أن الأوكرانيين
قد ذهبوا الآن إلى
عمليات دفاعية مضادة للهجوم ولكن بعد
ذلك  يوم الأحد ،
خرج رئيس المخابرات العسكرية الأوكرانية
ونشر مقطع فيديو لنفسه وهو جالس
على كرسيه وكان صامتًا في
نهايته ، وقال الأوكراني إن الخطط تحب
الصمت من الواضح مرة أخرى أنهم
لا يريدون التحدث عن
هجوم مضاد كبير إذا كان بالفعل قيد
التنفيذ بالفعل ولكن أحد الأشياء
الواضحة هو أنه في الوقت الحالي في هذا
البلد ، فإن الأوكرانيين لديهم بالتأكيد
مبادرة لا يوجد مكان حيث
يبدو أن الروس يحققون مكاسب ولكن هناك
الكثير من الأماكن حيث  من
المؤكد أن الأوكرانيين يحاولون جعل الألعاب واحدة
من تلك الأماكن حيث
قال الأوكرانيون مرة أخرى يوم الأحد إنهم
استعادوا الأراضي وهذا يأتي بعد
عدة أيام من المكاسب التي
يقول الأوكرانيون إنها كانت مهمة
فرانكين سي إن إن أوكرانيا